dragos I based on your location what's
your analysis of the authorities and the
law in um Romania and then what I see
being millions of the Matrix and the uh
worldwide cabal that wants to silence
um our brother and his brothers
basically we're basically uh colony
of the European Union and we're bitching
ourselves out to we're whoring ourselves
up to both the European Union and
um the United States
right now uh the geopolitical
waves or interests
are in such a way that we want to get
into the Schengen area so basically our
panties are down and we're bent over is
this and is this like a Witch Hunt where
they're trying to earn brownie points
from the West you know Brothers
I'm not sure if it's a Witch Hunt but
I'm sure it's a situation of if somebody
says that they should jump they ask how
high
all right I've noticed sorry Rich I've
noticed that with Ireland as well all
these small countries that have joined
the EU they want to they listen they
want to jump out high and they want to
be the best kid in the class it's just
ridiculous like and yeah I saw a notice
while I was back home in Ireland
recently and it was like a you know like
a public service notice at a bus stop
and uh are at an airport and the EU flag
was at the bottom and I stopped what my
what my girl I said do you see anything
wrong with that public service
announcement in that poster she's like
no I said yeah there's no Irish flag
there there's only an EU flag so it's
it's the same thing's gonna happen in
Romania when the call comes in from guy
vorstad or from Brussels do this take
this person out they're going to do it
I've actually went into a pretty heated
discussion with guy on Twitter
what's the non-elected he's an unelected
side bureaucrat he's one of the ugliest
people in Europe and he's got the worst
hairstyle but I think he's actually not
wrong on most things
but he is long wrong on some things and
he's very far off wrong so what is the
prediction that Britain was going to
rejoin the EU I doubt it
I doubt it I mean it's going to take a a
huge push from uh from the globalist uh
side of things dragos I want to ask you
what's what's the general uh like
consensus like what's the uh country
saying about this whole thing with
Andrew interest and Tate right now
everybody's kind of like
um divided in the sense that
you have people which have a bit of
critical thinking and they say like I
don't know Andrew I don't know what he's
done but it got remedy on the on the map
he's done that yeah everyone kind of
like how Borat put Kazakhstan yeah
besides besides that right like I'm
talking about people that don't know
Andrew or maybe have heard of Andrew
Tate and they're like
we don't know what's happening but
something's fishy and it stinks because
that's the same Playbook that they've
used
for everybody else that got rich and
Powerful in Romania
so that they could cancel them and bring
them down because it's happened to
politicians and other people in Romania
before and they've been successful
it depends on what you define by success
most of those people have exited the
public domain so is he still
sorry is he still in Cut are they still
in custody I thought I saw that they had
gotten around for 30 days until the end
of January
but he but Dylan uh arrest
because they denied the claim to Freedom
yeah my understanding is recently they
managed to get an order to seize more
assets like his car collection and
whatever assets they could get out of
his uh property so they're saying that
they need it to fund the uh claims
against them and also pay damages to
anybody that they uh might award damages
to in the future so this doesn't sound
like a catch and release type of
situation it sounds like it's going to
take some time to sort of deal with but
there's no question in my mind that he's
going to leave
uh like he said very nice things about
Romania over the last few years that
I've known him anyway uh both both
publicly and privately and I wouldn't I
wouldn't stay there either like you know
once he's out he's probably gonna bounce
yeah they've said very nice things about
Romania even while in custody yeah
I always wonder if it's one of those
things where they just want to make him
irrelevant so remember the name like
Milo yiannopoulos he was everywhere
years ago and then they kind of did this
whole thing on him and like no one even
thinks yeah no one thinks about him
anymore here's one remember Martin
shkreli the finance bro who bought like
insulin or something and raised it some
crazy amount and he was the most evil
man in the world a few years back I
didn't realize that he's had a job I
didn't even know if he went to jail he
popped up in my feed the other day I'm
like oh I remember that name watched
like two minutes of his cast and he's
just some like gaming Finance dork and
he's he's actually really smart really
bright I enjoy some of his content but
he just fell off the face of the Earth
in terms of the public sphere I'm
wondering if that's the end game with
the Tates like it doesn't really matter
if they get arrested as long as they
disappear before I finish
I didn't quite finish my reply there's
two types of people
that have their views than Romania about
one of them one of the categories is the
people that look at this as
um with a critical thinking type of view
even though they might know about Andrew
or Tristan or both of them or not
but they know that usually when
something like this happens and it's not
some wide-backed
um gorilla somewhere in a [__] second
great City in Romania pimping out some
um
whatever you want to use a word you want
to use checks that look like Grandma
um
those are the types of guides that get
busted for the accusations that they
have been busted on
so you got these people that look at
this and say okay something's up
I think it's an Al Capone type of
situation where they came into his house
on some bogus accusations they took the
laptops the PCS the hard drives
everything they went through that trying
to look for something else and now
they're finding something else and they
they're hitting them with the book
hoping that something will stick and
then you've got the second type of
people in Romania which are basically
um brainwashed idiots that watch TV
and they would read
um
news article and believe every single
word
even though they look at the facts
written in the article and it's like a
combination between an article written
in 2015 with some other piece of
information that was in 2019 and
something else to prove that something
happened in 2022. and it's like a total
um uh spaghetti word spaghetti sandwich
and they they don't have the critical
um thinking capacity to look through
that and see what it is
well I mean those are the two people
these days
critical thinking skill that's most
people these days critical thinking
skills has been just been sucked out of
everybody because
the powers to be don't want critical
thinkers right
different than Romania it's a bit
different in Romania in the sense that
even though my most people don't have
critical thinking they're very
um skeptical of mainstream media they're
very skeptical of the government yes I I
am because
no I'm noticing that too Drake is that I
agree for the first time ever back in
Ireland I have noticed that there is
skepticism Rising about the government
and I've given up waiting for to get to
The Conspiracy Theory or the conspiracy
theory to come through we all know that
the authorities were sent after the
Tates because of their influence on
young men and that the reason why my 14
year old son and every one of his Bros
follows these guys religiously they do
not want guys want getting unplugged
from The Matrix and that's why they took
him that's where they took him out
if
one reason why somebody would get
canceled out of their Uber account
well they canceled everything
simultaneously
what reason is there for that if that
was a coordinated attack it's it's yeah
there's a there's a worldwide cabal like
to cancel him everywhere there was a
meeting took place it was like you know
like remember the what was the mafia
Council you know that they had a they
said it didn't
we all knew what existed and there is a
globalist mafia Council as far as I'm
concerned it just said okay we need to
take this guy out because he's
unplugging young men yeah there's
there's clearly different levels to this
like there's a level that that tech
companies will operate at because for
Twitter Facebook meta insert like all
like all these platforms payment
processors stripe PayPal uh Airbnb for
all these guys to coordinate this very
quickly within a 24 to 48 hour period
they clearly like have a table somewhere
or or a hotline where they can deal with
stuff like this right like there's
there's different levels to the way that
the Matrix operates yeah second invasion
ground air and sea and they have to be
coordinated it used to be that those
sorts of actions wouldn't happen until
there was proof now it's just
allegations and I I I'm not so sure that
it's because he's unplugging young men
and because he's speaking truth I think
it's because he's offending the weak
betas out there that have had success
ass and they just take personal offense
to it they just don't like the guy
because they make he causes them to look
in the mirror and realize what trumps
they actually are and you know there's
nothing like a weak there's nothing more
dangerous right than we yeah right as
Jordan Peterson says and so there's
nothing more dangerous than a weak man
with power yes they have a lot of weak
men with power and so they see something
like Tate and they don't even care that
he's unplugging these young men because
they don't even care about the young men
registering thought they just don't like
how he makes them themselves feel and so
I think
a a great example of a a weak men as you
said a dangerous powerful weak men but
they're also the most vengeful and they
build it up over years and I think you
know one of those guys is Adam Schiff
you can tell that that guy was a soy
beta got beat up as a kid you know the
quarterback probably clothed his sister
and the guy is carrying it around for
effing years and like like the Nerds who
didn't get power when they were young
absolutely resent people who were able
to wield it and
these are the guys 50 that usually go
into law right like like one of the
common sound bites that you'll hear from
them is that the pen is mightier than
the sword because they realize that they
cannot wield a sword but they realize
how much power the pen has when you use
the law too right
I mean if there's anything as far as a
lesson here it's don't don't fly too too
close to the Sun and I think that he had
he had probably done that which is why
he's in a situation that he's in right
now right he's not too big too fast rich
I think you need to write that quote
down those who say the man the pen is
mightier than the swords say so because
they cannot wield the sword yeah
Yeah well yeah
I mean it's a common theme like I know a
lot of lawyers I mean I was married to
one right
yeah the the prosecutor that's on
State's case is also
one of the prosecutors of the um
people like uh person people trafficking
um director or somebody in charge
missing the word because it's legalese
in Romania and for him it's a good way
to advance in his career by getting
notorious
and very public cases
is human trafficking huge in Romania
like it is in the U.S like a lot of
people don't realize in the US we act
I've read this recently that we have
more slaves now than we did at any time
pre-civil I would just because I would
be surprised if those charges stick I
think if anything they might find
something on the other end when it comes
to
Capital being produced
and how it was produced whether or not
it you know complied with law I don't
know I mean
um it's it's a practice the world over
there's there's an attorney general in
the state of New York and she's gone
after Trump for the exact same reason
she just wants to make a name for
herself exactly yeah
and you know what I I hate to say well I
think top G is bigger than Trump so this
prosecutor is going to make himself
famous worldwide yeah yeah you must have
to hate someone and Trump's out of the
line right now you always have to eat
something over it you always have to
have an enemy the sad thing is is that
the human trafficking that uh you know
he's being accused of which is obviously
I'm 95 sure that's just totally bogus
right I always have some some reserved
but
what people don't realize
it's only a business because of weak men
strong men don't go to these uh drugged
out hell uh you know against their will
or prostitutes I mean come on it's a
bunch of Sims and betas and weak men out
there that fuel that whole economy I
mean it's just you know it's just it's
just nuts man and uh weak men are
destroying the world right now that's
what I've always wanted I tell guys like
for dating type advice like get get 2
000 followers on Instagram and have a
solid Instagram and see what happens
like you will have girls come into your
DMs and I've experienced that any guy
I've told that too they've done the work
on the online dating type side they've
experienced that so now amplify that by
just a multitude and then you get
someone like Tate this guy's he's the
most famous guy on the planet right now
do you really think that he has to
traffic chicks or that he has to drug
chicks or abuse them or yeah are they
lining up he's probably beating them
away or beating them off with with an
ugly stick like get out of here I've got
[__] to do I'll say this I mean like
every interaction that I've had whether
it was public in a podcast or or private
in conversations that I I've had I've
always been left with the opinion that
they're true gentlemen when it comes to
that so again I would be surprised if
any of that sticks most guys that get
higher guys that manage chicks are true
gentlemen like if they did the webcam
thing you're not gonna have girls work
for you and whether or not it complied
with law I don't know right yeah
between the uh people trafficking what
it is in the United States
and what it is in uh Romania because we
have slightly different definitions
where in uh the United States people
trafficking is usually getting people
from Mexico and taking them over the
border and bringing them into the U.S
over here if you talk to a chick and you
tell her I'm gonna marry you when you
come to Romania and then you have her on
only fans when she comes to Romania even
though she does it willingly
it's considered people trafficking it
because you told her that you would
marry her or begin a relationship with
her
if she did something for you
so it's a bit different like the
definition is very different
also
um
for example they would have
security right at the house where the
chicks were
because obviously four five six whatever
beautiful chicks staying in the same
house
attract some attention and you want some
security for them because that's what
you are doing basically you are
providing them a Carefree environment in
the Carefree world right this is the
understanding right and if you have
security there it's like
oh but you're not protecting them you're
keeping them from running away
right you see they're spinning it
everything
did Andrew actually run a did he manage
because I know he talks about how he
would manage uh women to help with only
only oh they've openly stated even on my
podcast there was like 75 Cows as they
run at one time yeah operation
what's what's the question
so uh so the tape brothers did manage
performers on only fans is that is that
is that a true statement if they were
managing them personally
no was he running a business where he
would help to maximize their income show
them how to do it because I remember
seeing some clips where he would have he
talked about like having dudes do the
typing because they actually knew what
to say to hook people in versus
did he actually run out of business
I cannot talk on what's happening now
because he never invited me to his home
and I don't know what his setup is
honestly like I see uh um
the types of statements that he does
online things that you could see by
yourself watching some podcasts and
that's as much as I know from now I know
that back in 2017 2018 where this was
the the beginning he used to run he
um innovated or
um invented this uh situation or this um
setup where he would have the chick on a
webcam site in the door next door and he
would be on his laptop actually chatting
to the people
instead of her so like the pictures with
her but yeah he has managed only fans
models right just like like this was
this was from 2017 2018 though yeah and
I'm not saying that
that he was breaking the law I'm just
clarifying that he has been in the
business of managing only fans models
yeah
um
yeah we're kind of like we're getting
into some speculation stuff and it's
it's like you know like a little bit of
golf at this point so
I'm going to investigation and I don't
want to like trip some wires or
something
um
yeah look you know the truth has a way
of of always revealing itself so give
that you know some time and you know the
facts will become clear and obvious you
know what I can tell you what I can tell
you
what I can tell you is that out of the
six chicks that were uh initially in
this lawsuit against him I think there's
maybe one or two left
well I guarantee there's some money
going to them for for them at this point
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out